in the last lecture i introduced us to
some of the main concepts
behind quantum physics in its early
years einstein played an essential role
in the development of these ideas
perhaps more so than any other
individual scientist
it's not an exaggeration to say that
with his 1905 paper on the photoelectric
effect in light quanta
einstein started the quantum revolution
as time went on however
einstein became less and less
comfortable with some of the strange
implications of the new quantum theory
and this often made it impossible for
him to constructively contribute to
development
of this new science instead of working
within the scientific
community to help build and understand
the quantum theory
einstein dug in his heels and stubbornly
refused to accept many of the new and
counter-intuitive conclusions that were
being reached
when it came to the development of the
quantum theory einstein played the role
of the contrarian
in this lecture we'll talk about the
strange implications
of quantum physics and we'll also talk
about how einstein responded to these
results and discoveries
we'll consider some of the objections
that einstein raised and discuss
some of the dead-end paths that he
pursued in his rather desperate attempts
to avoid accepting the quantum nature of
our world
recall that in 1905 einstein proposed
that light is not only a wave
but that it also consists of individual
particles or quanta
and eight years later in 1913 niels bohr
found that he could build a model of the
atom that solved the number of otherwise
difficult problems
but to do so he had to treat electrons
not only as particles but
also as waves let's pick up this story
about a decade
or so later in 1924 it wasn't this year
that a young french student named louis
de broly
completed his phd dissertation
in this dissertation de broglie built
upon and generalized
the earlier work of both einstein and
bohr
in einstein and bohr's earlier papers on
quantum physics the scope was
deliberately
very limited these papers only applied
to the case of photons for einstein
and two electrons in the case of bore
but de broglie took this kind of
thinking much farther
at its essence what the broly had
proposed in 1924
was that everything is simultaneously
both a particle
and a wave now if you're like most
people you're saying to yourself well
wait a minute
clearly not everything's a wave if you
pick up and examine some everyday object
like a baseball you won't notice any
wave-like characteristics
but according to nebroli the wave-like
features are there they're just really
hard to see
this is because the extent of an
object's waviness its quantum wavelength
is inversely proportional to its
momentum
a fastball moving at 100 miles per hour
for example has a wavelength of only
about 10 to the minus 34 meters
when this is compared to the size of the
baseball it's clear that the wave-like
nature of the baseball is far too tiny
to detect in any practical way so a
baseball might be a wave
but its wavelength is so small that its
wavelike features
are entirely imperceptible
following to broly's math it turns out
that the wave-like properties of matter
are in general only noticeable for very
small objects
and when i say very small i mean very
very small
even an almost stationary raindrop
moving at say one meter per year
has a wavelength of about 10 to the
minus 20 meters
so even its wavelike behavior would be
almost impossible to detect
to really identify the wave-like nature
of matter we have to consider
objects that are even smaller in
particular atoms or subatomic particles
we can consider an electron for an
example an electron within a typical
atom moves at a speed of around
20 million miles per hour making its
wavelength about 10 to the minus 10
meters according to the broly
this is pretty small but it's also about
the size of the atom itself
so in other words the electron's
wavelength is comparable
to the size of the region that it's
confined to
this means that you can't think of an
electron simply as a particle moving in
an orbit around a nucleus
although an electron is a singular
object a particle
it also acts very much like a wave
einstein himself was initially very fond
of the work of de broglie
and in many ways the broly's work served
to clarify some of the quantum ideas
that had been floating around in the
preceding years and decades
and importantly it connected and unified
einstein's idea of light quanta
with bohr's idea of electron waves
after reading the broly's dissertation
einstein helped to promote de broglie's
ideas
and probably more important he worked to
convince other scientists
that was imperative that these ideas be
tested experimentally
to do this one had to somehow find a way
to determine whether electrons do
or do not interfere with each other the
way that waves do
this suggestion probably seemed fairly
obvious to nebroli and to other
physicists who were working quantum
theory at the time
but unlike de broglie einstein was very
famous and his suggestions carried a lot
of weight
in any case a number of experimental
physicists were quickly convinced to
carry out exactly the kinds of
experiments that were needed at the time
by 1927 or so the answer was clear
electrons do in fact experience both
constructive and destructive
interference
electrons are not only particles they
also behave like
waves
throughout the mid and late 1920s a
great deal of effort was directed toward
developing a rigorous system of
mathematics that could be used to
describe
and calculate how quantum particle waves
behave and interact
in 1925 for example erwin schrodinger
developed an equation that describes the
wave-like behavior of electrons
the schrodinger equation is still taught
today to nearly all undergraduate
physics students
and it makes accurate predictions at
least for electrons that are moving at
speeds
far below the speed of light this new
generation of quantum theorists was not
content with the old quantum theory as
developed by einstein
bohr and de broly they were intent on
building a more complete
and more mathematically robust system
this system would become known
as quantum mechanics as the system of
quantum mechanics was being developed
einstein found himself more and more
troubled by its implications
at least with the concept of light
quanta there was some notion of what it
meant
for light to be a wave it had been long
established that light consists of
oscillating or vibrating electric and
magnetic fields
and the peaks of a light wave are those
points in space
where the electric and magnetic fields
are the strongest
but when it came to something like an
electron wave it wasn't at all clear
what the peaks of the wave really
represented
the key question about matter waves and
the question that was bothering einstein
was the following what exactly is waving
the issue at hand really comes down to
the same puzzle that we discussed in a
previous lecture
a classical wave makes sense because
it's made up of many
objects a water wave for example is the
highest at one point because there are
the most
water molecules at that point but the
wave of a single electron can't be
interpreted
in terms of the collective behavior of
many objects it's only one electron
after all
one object can't exhibit the kind of
collective behavior
that a water wave does in 1926
max born proposed a very radical answer
to this essential question
bourne argued that the shape of the wave
of an electron or of any other quantum
object
called the wave function should be
interpreted to represent the probability
of that object being found in a given
location when or if it were measured
if you conduct an experiment to
determine the location of a given
electron
there's a high probability that you'll
find it somewhere where the absolute
value of the wave function is very high
there's a much lower probability that
you'll find it in a place where the
absolute
absolute value of the wave function is
low as
bourne saw the problem there's no choice
but to view the wave of an electron in
terms of the probability of it being
found in a particular location
or in a particular configuration and
this soon became the standard way for
physicists to think about matter waves
and quantum mechanics
let's take a second to step back and ask
what this really means
according to born in his way of thinking
about quantum mechanics how should we
think about the electron
as it exists prior to being measured
well in some sense according to born the
electron is extended across the volume
of space that is covered by the wave
function
when we measure the location of an
electron it's always point like
without any spatial extent but before
it is measured an electron is
simultaneously in all the locations
that's covered by its wave function
it's in many places and all at the same
time
in this sense electrons and other
quantum objects have a kind of
probabilistic existence
being in all possible places and doing
all possible things
at all possible times this is sometimes
described in terms of what is known as
the heisenberg uncertainty principle
according this principle the more
precisely defined the location of a
quantum object is
the less specified is its velocity and
vice versa
according to quantum mechanics an object
cannot be in only one place and moving
at only one speed
at this point in time you're probably
feeling a bit confused and you should be
this is bizarre and incredibly
counter-intuitive stuff
quantum mechanics describes a kind of
existence that is beyond strange
and is fundamentally different from
anything that we as human beings
normally
normally experience as niels moore once
famously remarked
anyone who is not shocked by quantum
theory has not
understood it so to try to develop an
intuition for how electrons and other
quantum objects behave let's consider
a simple example this will also help us
to understand what einstein found to be
so objectionable in these new ideas
picture an electron the electron is
described by a wave function
that peaks sharply at two places we'll
call them locations a
and b and let's say that the shape of
the wave function
covers locations a and b equally and to
the same extent
in this case if we were to conduct an
experiment to measure the location of
the electron
there would be a 50 chance that we'd
find it a location a and a 50
chance that we'd find it at location b
at first glance this seems something
like a coin flip
something with two equally likely
outcomes but comparing this to
a coin flip misses something important
about the role that probability plays in
quantum mechanics
so imagine that i flip a coin and then i
cover it up
before seeing which side is up at this
moment i might be tempted to think
that this is like the electron in our
example after all when i uncover the
coin
there'll be a 50 chance it'll be heads
and 50 chance that it will be tails
but there is a crucial difference
between the electron and the coin in
these examples
in the case of the coin the coin is
already in a uniquely heads
or uniquely tails configuration we just
haven't uncovered it yet to find out
which side is facing up
but in the case of the electron it is
not uniquely in location a or uniquely
in
location b it is in both locations a
and b simultaneously according to born
in his way of interpreting quantum
mechanics the electron exists
simultaneously in all of locations that
are covered by the extent
of the wave function
in the case of the coin we're merely
ignorant of which side is facing up
but in the case of the electron it's not
a matter of us not knowing where it's
located
in reality it is not in location a or
location b it is in location a and
location b it is in both locations at
once
in december of 1926 einstein wrote a
letter to max born expressing his
skepticism
of the new interpretation of quantum
theory in this letter
einstein made one of the most famous and
often quoted remarks
let me read you just a few sentences
from this letter
quantum mechanics is very impressive but
an inner voice tells me that it's not
yet the real thing
the theory says a lot but does not bring
us any closer to the secret of the old
one
i at any rate am convinced that he does
not play
dice einstein expressed sentiment
similar to this one on many occasions
throughout his life
in various ways einstein became fond of
insisting that god does not play dice
with the universe
but what exactly did einstein mean when
he said this kind of thing
to understand the nature of einstein's
objection it's important to appreciate
the role that determinism plays
in classical physics according to the
equations of classical physics all
future events at least in principle
can be calculated and predicted with
perfect accuracy
if somehow i could know the exact
location and velocity of every atom and
every other particle in the universe
and if i had access to an infinitely
powerful computer then i could use the
equations of classical physics
to work out everything that would ever
happen in the future
and i could run these equations
backwards to work out everything that
had ever happened in the past
in effect in classical physics the
future is strictly determined by the
present
the universe is like a great and complex
clock simply ticking forward in a
complicated
but entirely predictable manner
this was a vision of the universe that
einstein liked
no no role for chance or probability
according to classical physics
the god of classical physics does not
play dice
but according to max born and his
understanding of quantum mechanics
the universe is not as predictable as it
is in classical physics
think again about our example of an
electron with a wave function that
covers both locations a and b
if we know absolutely everything there
is to know about the electron
there is no way whatsoever to reliably
predict
where we'll find it even if we know the
shape of the electron's wave function
exactly
there's still a 50 chance that we'll
find it at location a
and a 50 chance that we'll find it at
location b
in choosing between these two possible
outcomes the universe is not behaving
deterministically
unlike the deterministic universe that's
described at classical physics
the quantum universe is fundamentally
probabilistic
this is what einstein was talking about
when he objected to god playing dice
with the universe
in his gut einstein felt that the
universe and its laws must be strictly
deterministic
at nature's foundation einstein felt
that there could be no role
for probability or chance
let me take a minute to clarify an
important point about einstein's views
regarding determinism
and probability in some more practical
ways
einstein was perfectly comfortable with
the roles that chance and probability
can play in physics
if i flip a coin there's no practical
way to predict how it will land
in principle this could be reliably
calculated through the laws of classical
physics
but in practice this is an impossible
task there's not a supercomputer in the
world that's powerful enough to
accurately predict
whether a coin will land with its head
or tail side facing up
even an extremely tiny change in how my
thumb strikes the coin
or in the microscopic shape of the coin
or in the distribution of the
surrounding air molecules
could change the outcome of any given
coin flip
so although the laws of classical
physics are strictly deterministic
many situations are in practice highly
chaotic and impossible to predict
this makes it impossible to actually put
this kind of determinism
to real use and einstein knew this and
it this kind of practical indeterminism
didn't bother him at all what did bother
einstein was the prospect of
real indeterminism built deep into the
underlying
laws of physics this kind of
indeterminism would make it impossible
for even an all-knowing being to predict
perfectly something's outcome it was
this kind of indeterminism
that seemed to be present in the new
theory of quantum mechanics
and this brings me to another thing
about this famous einstein
quote and i feel obliged to clarify it
on this point
the statement that god does not play
dice with the universe is often
presented
as proof that einstein was a religious
man or that he believed in god
in fact however this is not at all the
case it's well documented that einstein
didn't subscribe to any traditionally
religious or otherwise theistic beliefs
he did like to use the word god
as an evocative metaphor but he also
made it repeatedly clear that he was not
talking about the god of the bible
or of any other religion when i was
preparing this lecture i had originally
decided that i wouldn't bring up this
point at all
but then i came across a series of
statements by einstein and in these
statements
einstein seemed to be really bothered by
how his remarks were often
misinterpreted in this way
for example there was a 1954 news report
that inaccurately described einstein as
religious
in response einstein wrote the following
remarks
it was of course a lie what you read
about my religious convictions
a lie which is being systematically
repeated
i do not believe in a personal god and
i've never denied this but have
expressed it clearly
if something is in me which can be
called religious then it is
the unbounded admiration for the
structure of the world so far as our
science can reveal it
on this and on many other occasions
einstein made it very clear that he did
not believe in miracles
he did not believe in the existence of
an immortal soul or of any form of
afterlife
other than during his childhood einstein
didn't attend any synagogue or church
or otherwise participate in any
organized religion
he did however frequently refer to the
sense of wonder and awe
that he experienced in contemplating our
universe and its laws
to einstein his science and his religion
were inseparable
okay so back to the debate about the
meaning and interpretation
of quantum mechanics in the late 1920s a
consensus was starting to form
around a refined version of max borne's
interpretation
this view became known as the copenhagen
interpretation named for the city where
niels bohr werner heisenberg
and others had made major contributions
to its development
according to the copenhagen view of
quantum mechanics quantum particles
behave like waves
these particle waves are each described
by their wave function the shape of a
given particle's wave function
represents the probability
that it will be found at different
locations or with different velocities
generally speaking quantum particles
exist in multiple locations at once
and have multiple velocities all
simultaneously
but according to the copenhagen
interpretation whenever an observation
of a particle is made
its wave function collapses and the
measured quantity takes on
a single measured value
in our earlier example prior to any
measurement or observation
the electron is in locations a and b
both simultaneously
but an active observation causes its
wave function to collapse
and its location takes on a single value
either a or b
so how did the scientific consensus come
to form around the copenhagen
interpretation
and what did the physicists working on
quantum mechanics think about the nature
of their theory during this period of
time
the answer to this question probably
depends a lot on when exactly you ask
them
during the late 1920s the theory was
evolving so quickly
that someone could easily have a very
different opinion in 1927
than they did in 1926. furthermore these
scientists were scattered all over
europe
and they generally communicated with
each other through letters and through
publications and scientific journals
these ways of communicating were usually
pretty slow
and they could often leave important
questions unanswered in a way that a
phone call
or better yet an in-person meeting might
not
for all of these reasons scientific
conferences were especially important
in the role in the development of
quantum mechanics and none was more
important or influential
than the fifth solve a conference on
physics which was held in brussels
in october of 1927.
in attendance at this meeting were
nearly all of the major players who'd
been contributing to quantum mechanics
during this period
it was the all-star team of quantum
physics this included einstein of course
but also irwin schroedinger max born
niels bohr louis de broglie
paul dirac and werner heisenberg and
this is not to mention wolfgang paulie
marie curie
and max plonk of the 29 physicists in
attendance
17 of them had either already been
awarded a nobel prize
or would eventually be awarded one
at the 1927 soul they conference it
became clear that a consensus view was
starting to form
around the copenhagen interpretation
most of those in attendance seemed to
have accepted the probabilistic nature
of their new theory there was a general
acceptance
that this was likely to be a real aspect
of nature
and not something that would be
explained away when they better
understood the problem
for example max born werner heisenberg
and niels bohr were each
fully aware that the universe is
described by quantum mechanics was
fundamentally
probabilistic and while they
acknowledged that there was still some
chance
that determinism could somehow be
restored in some future
revision of the theory they each thought
that this was pretty unlikely
unlike einstein they were prepared to
accept the lack of determinism in the
subatomic world
einstein was unwilling to accept any
version of quantum mechanics
in which god played dice with the
universe and when einstein declared this
niels bohr simply replied by telling
einstein
to stop telling god what to do
by this time many physicists including
bohr heisenberg and bourne
felt that the quantum revolution was
coming to a close
they had a perfectly good working theory
and it was not at all clear that any
major new elements were needed beyond
those that they already had
but einstein was still far from
accepting this new consensus view of
quantum mechanics
he felt sure that big pieces of the
theory were somehow still missing
to be clear einstein was not exactly
arguing that the new theory of quantum
mechanics was incorrect
the schrodinger equation the other
equations of this theory described a
great deal of phenomena very well
and the successes of quantum mechanics
were entirely undeniable
so instead of claiming that quantum
mechanics was incorrect
einstein was arguing that it was somehow
incomplete
think back to our example of the
electron that's described by a wave
function
which extends across locations a and b
according to the consensus copenhagen
interpretation
the electron exists in both of these
locations simultaneously
but einstein was skeptical of this maybe
he thought the electron is really in
only one of these places at a given time
but destroying our equation perhaps
couldn't tell us which
if that were true then the apparent
determine in determinism in quantum
mechanics
might just be an illusion he imagined
that there could be another more
complete equation
that would make it possible to calculate
the location of the electron
at a given time without any
probabilistic results
in essence einstein was looking for a
way to make sense of quantum mechanics
that is not only deterministic but in
which the properties of each particle or
object
are always well defined
in early 1927 einstein started working
toward developing a version of quantum
mechanics
that he hoped could explain all of the
observed phenomena of quantum mechanics
while still
allowing the laws of nature to be
strictly deterministic
the class of theories he would end up
developing and later advocating for
became known as hidden variable theories
according to these theories the wave
function of a particle as used in the
schrodinger equation
doesn't tell you everything about that
particle
the wave function was in effect an
incomplete
or partial description of the particle
by hypothesizing
other variables that are missing from
the wave function einstein hoped to
avoid the need for any indeterminism in
the theory
at the solevei conference einstein
argued vigorously that the copenhagen
version of the quantum theory was
fatally flawed
and that a more complete theory was
needed but despite these arguments
he wasn't able to convince many of his
colleagues
in a series of informal but public
discussions with niels bohr
einstein raised what he saw as a series
of major problems with the copenhagen
interpretation
but one after the other bohr responded
effectively to einstein's criticisms
in each case boer found holes in
einstein's arguments
and successfully defended the new
consensus view
by the end of the meeting it was clear
to most of the scientists in attendance
that bohr had bested einstein in these
debates
the copenhagen interpretation is weird
there's no doubt about that
but it also seems to be self-consistent
einstein however was far from giving up
and he was undeterred by his failure at
the solevei conference to demonstrate
any fatal flaws in the copenhagen
interpretation
in the years it followed he continued to
search for a more complete version of
quantum mechanics
that he hoped would restore determinism
to the subatomic world
and furthermore he hoped that such a
theory would allow for a more
straightforward description of electrons
and other quantum particles
he wanted to avoid things like objects
being in multiple places at once
and restored a quantum mechanics what
philosophers sometimes call
realism in the next lecture we'll pick
up where we left off here
we'll talk about einstein's effort and
ultimate failure to build a more
complete
and fully deterministic version of
quantum mechanics
and we'll explore two famous thought
experiments schrodinger's cat
and what's known as the einstein
podolsky rosen paradox
[Music]
you